hey everyone what's up I'm a Paralympic
snowboarder I am a free skier we are
bobsledders Thank You skaters today
we're doing Olympic support how does one
try out a ski jump to find out they're
any good at it I'd love to do it to be
the next Eddie Eagle I think that it's
exactly like that you have to just try
it to see if you're good at it I mean
like to get to where I am in the sport
or the other guys on the team it's so
many years and everything but it all
started at the same spot on a tiny tiny
jump skiing small tricks and then you
slowly progressed so you gotta start at
the bottom have you ever been stuck on a
ski lift it happened to me at Wolf Creek
back in 1978 yes I have been stuck the
worst time was on Christmas Eve late at
night it was an hour and a half we were
sitting there I had no goggles on it was
very cold
it's a tweet from mrs. Jacobson my
first-grade students are working on an
Olympic project they would like to know
what the hardest trick in figure skating
is United stands one of the most
difficult tricks or elements that's the
technical term is twizzles and twizzles
are rotating turns done on one foot that
needs to be done across the ice in
unison so that would be one of the
harder tricks oh yeah we're good at them
how in the world do figure skaters land
like that three question marks I'm gonna
break my legs and arms and hit my head
and die man it's really refreshing to
see a tweet where someone's questioning
the difficulty because with bigger
skating you want things to look
effortless but it definitely takes a lot
of training both on and off the ice so
practice practice this tweet is from
Jeff Bernard how hard is the bobsled
feel the rhythm feel the rise absolute
is actually very intense when we go down
the track we go about 75 to 95 miles an
hour and we reach up to 5 G's of
pressure if you never have felt a G it's
hard to explain until you've gone down
and felt it so we do feel the rhythm and
we do feel the rhyme and we'd rather
feel that than the g-forces Sophia ask
does anyone understand how Bob so it
works why do they have all these heats
so if you've ever watched track and
field you
heats prelims semifinals finals bobsled
is a very same thing but all of those
heats count so instead of track and
field where they start new each time and
then whoever goes on goes on and that
fastest time counts bobsled counts your
prelim time your semi-final time your
final time and whoever has the lowest
time at the end of it wins this tweet is
from ASAP Nubian does anyone know how
the inside of a bobsled looks like or
how they turn hashtag just wondering so
the inside of a bobsled looks very basic
there's not a lot in there there's not a
lot of padding it's mostly carbon fiber
and sometimes fiberglass the inside the
sled as drivers we do have a seat but
the brakeman just sit in the back with
their heads in between their legs their
legs stretched out and they're just
along for the ride so as drivers we're
doing most of the work down the track we
actually drive by a pulley system so
there's two rings in the shape of DS we
hold a straight part of these and they
attach two ropes in front of our sled
which then attach to our runners which
are blades and they move left and right
so if you want to move left you move the
left d-ring towards you you want to go
right you pull the right d-ring towards
you and it's back and forth like that
this is from Olivia right bit confused
about these Paralympic categories how is
some of them with no legs equal to
someone with one leg so I've got two
prosthetic legs I'm the only female
Paralympic snowboarder with two
prosthetic legs I'm racing against girls
who have one prosthetic leg above the
knee it's not exactly fair but they make
it as fair as they can
everybody's challenges are different so
if you're an arm amputee they'll put arm
amputee together if you're a below the
knee leg amputee or below the knee leg
impairment they put you together and if
you're above the knee impairment or
you've got two legs that are impaired
they put you together so they really do
the best that they can if anything
racing against girls who have their legs
and who have one good leg just motivates
me to Train that much harder what kinds
of terrain features do Paralympic
snowboarder space and snowboard cross
events so our snowboard cross event is
the same as the Olympic snowboard cross
event we have berms
basically turns against the wall we've
got jumps
we've got rollers we're side by side so
it's pretty much exactly like the other
snowboard cross you see except instead
of having four people side by side we
only have two people side by side which
makes it that much more competitive
because you have to want it no you have
to win every single race you're in to
advance why is sled hockey not more
popular it's actually amazing
I'm not sure why it's not that popular
it is amazing if you like hockey you're
gonna like sled hockey this fast-paced
hard-hitting you know we kind of joked
that stand-up players got it a little
easier they skate with their legs and
then shoot with their arms so you have
to skate with our arms and shoot with
the arms when you see a stand-up player
get checked on the boards that top part
of the board's flex well that bottom
part and sled hockey doesn't flex so we
absorb all of that hit when you're down
there on the ice so definitely a popular
sport and I can't wait to see it get
more popular alright so the first
question is from a Graham Merritt and
they asked in the guided skiing at the
Paralympics do the guides get medals as
a Paralympic ski race or a visually
impaired ski racer it is a team sport in
the able-body ski racing it's one
athlete in Paralympic visually-impaired
ski racing it's two so both athletes do
receive a medal these really impaired
downhill skiing at the Paralympics
surely that's just dangerous it's just
crazy you know skiing could be
classified as dangerous for anybody
whether you have a disability or not and
I feel as though visually impaired
skiing is probably just as safe as
anybody going out there skiing on their
own from Wayne C yang cross-country
skiing sitting looks very exhausting it
is how do they build up endurance the
way you build up endurance actually goes
way back about two years because it
takes about that time to get your base
up and it's a lot of cross-training so I
do a lot of long our rides a lot of long
our skis just going easy in your zone
wanting to caissons from phil wonder how
many skiers qualify for Paralympics
through
jury sustained well skiing I didn't get
my injury from skiing but I personally
know so many guys who do alpine skiing
from getting injured from alpine skiing
you know when you truly love something
you have a passion for it it doesn't
matter how you do it just sometimes
getting out and doing it is all that
matters
Bella Dube who knew buying a snowboard
was so difficult come on now it's not
that hard there's so many user guides
and equipment reviews out there when I
look for a snowboard
I'm looking for one that's gonna be the
right size the right width and generally
for the type of snowboarding that I want
to do backcountry freeride powder
they're all sort of built into these
different categories so it's best to
think about what kind of snowboarding
you want to do and find the one that
fits that category best how does one get
sponsored in snowboarding I think the
key to getting sponsorship is definitely
reaching out asking for what you need
you know whether you want to compete or
just do filmmaking you just gonna have
to get your name out there
spread some love chew Becca says so that
that is it difficult to snowboard
yes no people always like skiing is
easier to learn but harder to get good
at and snowboarding is hard to learn but
easier to get good at so I feel like
once you get the basic sound like the
turning and stuff you'll be in the park
in no time so there you go you guys
thank you for watching Olympic support
I'm gonna take my figure skates and head
out of here